let's just cross over to this press
conference being given by the families
of Israelis in Tel Aviv um injured in a
gun battle I mean they were all
civilians at a music festival in they
were fish in a barrel sitting in this uh
bomb shelter terrorists came to the door
they were throwing grenades in shooting
machine guns and we know that hersh's
arm from the elbow down was um severed
was blown off and that he tied a
tourniquet around with his shirt and
Hamas came in after the gunfire settled
down and said anyone who can walk stand
up and walk out we are told that he was
completely calm I think he was probably
in shock and he got up and he walked out
with five other people young people from
the music
Festival two young women three other
young men they were put on a pickup
truck and driven Away by Hamas and then
the police told us one thing they knew
is that the last known signal cell
signal from his phone was on the border
with
Gaza so not much to add chush was at the
festival with one of his best friends on
a shapir
uh I ey witness accounts from the people
we talked to who are in this bomb
shelter um several people independent of
each other said your son and his friend
anir uh saved Our Lives anybody's alive
because as grenades were being thrown in
they were tossing them back out they
were trying to comfort people and so um
I just uh thought I would add that maybe
you could add just the of the family in
the United States sure I'll just say
that uh Rachel and I both grew up in
Chicago we were living in California in
2000 when HH was born we made aliat
Israel as a family in the summer of 2008
when H who's our oldest
child he was uh 7 and a half almost
eight when we moved to Israel in the
summer of 2008 we've been living in
Jerusalem ever
since uh we have two daughters 2017 and
I just want to take one minute to talk a
little bit about HH he is a smiley
funloving guy um and people of all ages
just gravitate towards him and if you
mention his name to his friends his
teachers my friends our friends um you
mention his name and people just smile
because he's the kind of guy who's just
fun to be around and makes people feel
good and have a good time uh um he's got
a few passions one of which is traveling
the world and he's been saving his money
to go on his big trip at the end of
December hi thank you everybody for
coming my name is Nal Neta um the eldest
son for
adriena
um as this strategy was unfolded on
Saturday morning me and my other
siblings were talking to my mom on the
phone trying to calm her
down um things
were sort
of calm when she heard a lot of gunfire
outside of her shelter and we tried to C
her
down that's when I dropped off the
call and um both my brother and my
sister
we're on the call with her as the
terrorist barged into her
home and we he heard a little bit of
screaming and that's uh that was our
last contact with
her um there was no shooting on the call
and the neighbors downstairs also didn't
hear any
shooting my mom used um the little bit
of Arabic that she picked up working as
a nurse in the hospital in Soka for 20
years to count down the
terrorist and it is our hope which is a
little bit ridiculous at this stage to
say that um the optimistic scenario is
that she's held hostage in Gaza and not
dead on the street of the kibuts where
we go
up my mom is a 66 year-old
lady proud mother of me and my three
other siblings who are in the room with
me along with
seven go kids no
myself she was sitting on the porch of
her home in bery in on Saturday morning
when This ferocious attack happened
my mom devoted her life to helping other
people of all Races and
genders in her practice as a nurse in
the hospital in the neav in
Beva she installed this passion for
people in US her
kids and her
grandkids
as I said our last contact with my mom
was Saturday morning around 9:45 a.m. as
the tourist purged into her shelter in
in her home in
Berry there
are a lot of
images um kind of spreading around which
I don't feel the need to talk
about I want to
bring
forward the
responsibility that the Israeli
government has to bring back all the
hostages that
are kept in hostage by the Hamas
terrorists while saying this I want also
to speak about the
responsibility that the US
Administration president B
Biden and the secretary of state blinkin
has for the lives of every US citizen
that is out there and they are
responsible to bringing the US citizens
back home safe and
sound we expect nothing less from the US
Administration and from President Biden
and vice
and secretary St
blinkin I speak for in the name of
myself and my
family and I wish for the
quick solution for
this terrible terrible situation that
all of us are in
we never imagined that this
is how it will
[Music]
look thank you again for
coming I'm and though we've been
listening to a heart-wrenching press
conference given by American families of
relatives who've been caught up in the
attacks by Hamas on Saturday morning in
southern Israel people taken from the
music festival where also 260 bodies
were found and from kabut we know that
more than 100 people have been taken
captive by Hamas and taken back into
Gaza here we are hearing from relatives
of the missing people who are appealing
to the Israeli government and the us to
bring their loved ones back let's speak
now to Charles statford he's in kafar
Asar and this is a scene Charles of one
one of the scenes of that horrific
attack that unfolded on Saturday morning
and took so many people by surprise not
least the Israeli authorities and left
so many people
killed that's right and that terrible
testimony that you heard from that
gentleman
one can only imagine you'd get similar
testimonies from the relatives of the
people killed in kafar AAR now the
military now say that they are complete
control of the village that we're
standing standing next to um scenes
inside though are are quite
incredible So Many Bodies many
Palestinian Fighters but also many many
civilians and so the military tell us
many civilians both Israelis and foreign
workers they've got no idea yet how many
people were killed in the attack here
and you literally you see homes that
have been completely destroyed remnants
of people's lives strewn out across
manicured Lawns this was a beautiful
place to live somewhere in stark
contrast to of course across the border
in Gaza there is a fence that runs on
the western side alongside the village
and there is a huge hole in it breached
by those Hamas and those Palestinian
Fighters that came in on Saturday we
also have seen evidence of um other
means by which they crossed the border a
destroyed paraglider which the Israeli
military say was used by Hamas Fighters
there are no civilians left inside the
village now those that survived were
evacuated we have spoken to somebody who
did survive
her testimony sounded absolutely
terrifying hunkered down in her house
listening to the shooting and the
explosions outside after those Hamas
Fighters came in on the road here as
well um cars that have seemingly
evidence would suggest literally swerved
off the road as a means of trying to
avoid gunfire and crashed into barriers
rolled into ditches have been shot to
pieces and then blown up bodies also in
around those areas in the fields so it
is a terrible shocking situation that uh
that has occurred here um as I say the
military still counting the bodies still
retrieving the bodies from the homes in
which they were killed meanwhile
constant barrage of of of firing um as
the Israeli Air Force and artillery in
areas close to here Target uh places in
the Gaza Strip
um and of course there are Rockets being
fired out as well from from Gaza every
20 minutes or so there's an alarm goes
off an alert and the soldiers here and
the rescue teams the people that have
come to collect the bodies the
Medics hit the floor so the situation is
very tense here and although the Israeli
military are claiming that they have
taken or regained control of towns like
kafar AAR and towns like biri from where
that man we heard in that press
conference was describing his relatives
who he believes were killed were from
the military are very concerned here
that there could well be Hamas and
Palestinian Fighters still at large
hiding in the countryside around here um
earlier there was an incident in the
village of zikim which is just North of
the Gaza Strip um we can confirm now
that there was indeed clashes there
between uh Palestinian Fighters and the
Israeli military the Israeli military
saying that four Fighters were killed as
they tried to breach that area around
zikim um and that that hole in the fence
here in kafar AAR is one of dozens we
believe that uh were used by the
Palestinian fighters in order to cross
into Israel one other update is that
according to the military they have now
completed their count of those killed
inside um or the Israelis killed or the
Israeli civilians or let's just say
civilians living on this side of the
Border whether they be Israelis or
foreign workers they say in the village
of biri alone
108 civilians were found killed there
that's 10% of the population of that
Village Charles as you said there
there's very few people left around
there certainly not in Kar which you've
just been seeing but you have spoken to
some people who you've come across what
have their main feelings been what have
they been telling you about the events
of the past few
days everybody is in a state of complete
and utter shock those that we've spoken
to there's a lot of anger as well
growing anger um interestingly last
night when we were in this area as well
there were a lot of Israeli civilians
that were coming up to the military sh
sh great support handing out food
wishing their soldiers luck as we
believe that there could well be some
sort of ground offensive when that
happens we don't know yet there's also
as I say a lot of anger we were in the
town of stot which is about 3 kilomet uh
Northeast of Gaza this morning and we
spoke to a man who was very candid and
very angry and he said we' basically got
to kill them all um and I don't think he
was actually referring just to Hamas
either that is an indication of the
level of hate that this attack has
actually is is generating in communities
in towns and Villages along these
borders um he said we want to cut off
their electricity cut off their water we
want to basically cut off their food
starve them if necessary they have to
pay for what has happened here so yeah
um terrible situation and of course the
sentiments that that is generating show
the level of anger and the level of hate
that uh that is being felt here by many
many Israelis okay Charles thank you
very much for bringing us such a clear
picture and Vivid picture of the scene
there in southern Israel